après seize mois de recherches
infructueuses les enquêteurs ont enfin
une première preuve tangible de
l'écrasement du vol 370 de la malaysia
airlines c'est confirmé le morceau
d'aile retrouvait sur l'île de la
réunion il y a une semaine vient bel et
bien de l'appareil qui avait décollé de
kuala lumpur le 8 mars 2014 à
destination de pékin avec 239 personnes
à bord et qui est disparu des radars au
dessus de l'océan indien après avoir
brusquement changé de cap
alors frédéric le débris le morceau dès
la dérive est vraiment très loin de la
zone où se concentraient les recherches
comment à ce qu'il a pu arriver là mais
justement c'est lui donc il y avait
vraiment de zones sur lesquelles les
équipes de recherche ont focalisé les
efforts d'abord c'était aux alentours de
kuala lumpur ensuite ça s'est déplacé au
large à l'est des côtes australiennes et
donc qu'est ce qui s'est passé et bien
on pense que pendant 500 jours donc ce
débris a continué de dériver avec les
courants marins là qu'ils se sont
promenés dans l'océan indien pour
finalement aboutir sur cette petite île
de rien du tout là ce petit point des
vraiment une petites épingles halles de
l'île de la réunion alors maintenant
comment ce qu'on est capable de dire que
c'est bel et bien le morceau qui
appartenait à ce boeing 777 en fait
c'est boeing dont qui a pu voir un code
qui était inscrit sur le flap rond qu'on
a retrouvée il y avait deux possibilités
ils ont vraiment éliminer un des deux
cas et ensuite mais il restait juste le
vol 372 donc c'est un début un
relancement si vous venez de l' enquête
qui piétine quand même maintenant depuis
plus de 16 mois
cela fait cinq cent quinze jours que le
mystère reste entier cinq cent quinze
jours de recherches incessantes et
surtout d'élaboration de nombreuses
théories pour comprendre ce qui est
réellement arrivé au vol 370 de la
malaysia airlines
une disparition énigmatique qui a plongé
les familles des 239 victimes dans la
stupeur la plus totale un désespoir qui
demeure aujourd'hui encore sans
soulagement
et ce n'est pas la confirmation de
l'origine de ce morceau de deux mètres
de long qui permet d'amorcer le deuil
des familles
ils doivent encore trouver l'avion au
complet et nos conjoints a dit celle ci
il reste bien des réponses dit il que
nous n'avons jamais obtenu depuis le
jour de la disparition
mais alors que s'est-il passé pourquoi
une telle déviation de trajectoire
pendant sept heures est ce un
détournement un accident la piste
terroriste doit elle être définitivement
écarté des questions qui trouveront
peut-être un jour une ébauche de réponse
grâce à ce flot pourront retrouver par
hasard sur l'île de la réunion est un
cadeau pour les enquêteurs parce que
c'est le premier morceau officielle qui
confirme la thèse de l'écrasement de ce
vol c'est donc un nouveau départ pour
les enquêteurs chinois français
britanniques malaisien et australiennes
prochaine étape intensifier les
recherches au large des côtes de
l'australie
là où l'avion se serait écrasé un
frédéric oui ça vient relancer l'
enquête et c'est très bien mais on est
encore loin d'avoir toutes les réponses
tout cas ce qu'elle ré beaucoup c'est de
retrouver les boîtes noires mais là on
est loin de ça parce qu'en fait c'est
juste un morceau donc c'est trop peu
pour reconstituer avoir un véritable
casse tête donc on va quand même
intensifier les recherches peut être une
piste à explorer ce lundi times est
important vous savez sur le fameux flat
pro on a retrouvé des crustacés des
coquillages et c'est ça pourrait
peut-être permettre de localiser
l'endroit où on trouve ce genre de
coquillages alors en attendant les
écouter c'est vrai les fameuses boîtes
noires on les a toujours pas retrouvé et
même si on les retrouve et un jour y'a
rien qui indique en fait qui pourrait
vraiment nous livrer les secrets par
exemple quelles étaient les dernières
conversations dans le cockpit donc on
est très très loin mais c'est un début
oui c'est un début merci frais compris